all right everybody you have all come
here to be part of a bun review it's
okay to be afraid
many of you may not be coming back and
change it kid cohering patcher
we need a Harry Potter would to be a
Harry Potter this is Harry Potter he's
grown a lot just like the real movie and
he is going to school no no he's not
going to school in this one he's that oh
my god running kids I was trying to kill
him but something's always trying to
kill him this is amazing new and he
decides to hide himself in this safest
place there is a wedding
Rhonda and then this girl named
hermaphrodite
Hermione no appreciates hermaphrodites
and that it was her worm her mat for
dorks we need to remember towards people
Africa will need you for this ego wait
yes we do go back there's any parents of
hermaphrodites to be the parent y-yes
because you look very alike oh yes you
will be the bestest with her Manfred
dork actually erases the memory of her
parents that so that she can save them
it's kind of weird don't see them
friends who remember from Africa yeah
that's true I mean is it like hey guys
Manfred or I don't know we just like to
keep photos of Blink walls but then the
wizard Nazis are taking over ever come
to then Harry and hermaphrodite or bleep
you didn't have to go find a BFF
necklace they will stop Boulevard
so then all of them decided to drink
this magic potion to turn them into
somebody else three and then Ron Weasley
gets to make out with an older lady look
Weasley enough believe me okay all right
just against replicas yes he makes out
with the other lady hey
it is a kid movie within something very
unexpected heavy right way to mean this
movie singing a lot like that other
fantasy films well there's nothing but
walking and magic Lord of the things in
order to fly oh no no this is a
completely different movie now let's
talk about the eerie magic jewelry that
turns people into jerks
oh who has to be the evil piece of
jewelry all right now where him
oh you where him so easily it's like I'm
tired of you I want you to choose right
now from Avatar
are you on Team Potter or team Weasley -
I'm agin him but then intuitive
attention Harry and her so they may come
across at this sword in the water
I guess the lady in the lake is
renovating look just because some
moissan bit louder photography doesn't
mean it's some rigid form of government
so they're easily comes back but then
for some very confusing reason he has to
fight the most evilest thing he can
think of an agent Harriet her Manfred or
making out come on
I said nitrate maybe we are to do the
dirt down you know for kids didn't go
over the don't hit me with her to lived
in a shoe who wants to be don't hit me
was religion issue so then he see it
tells them about the deathly hallows I'm
gonna tell you about the Deathly Hallows
once upon a time there's a million
people about cream and a famous horse
gonna try to kill him when they get a
proper disguise they decide to make
Harry hype up the ugly way let's become
ugly so then they come across a witch
named Bellatrix
sounds like a minister who has any
benefits you you look like a little
bottom tighter you dummy
but then damn she comes in dough with
some mystic ass
okay who wants to be tubby how many of
you want to be Dobby did you see
Griffin Davi makes everybody disappear
oh forget me change but then Helena
Beatrix Connor throws at them they
arrive at a different place oh my god
the one character that everybody hated
in the movies and only made like what
appearance is dying I'm so sad
hey Harry Potter movies lighten up and
you're the first minutes ago weeks ago
an eternity to tune and are always dying
again flashed up and dad me Toki it has
a happy ending
Voldemort goes to the corpse of Gandalf
to do dad knows went but Danny finds his
magic wand the end of the movie we're
pleased to end it higher that's I quit
seven there's only one more plug
right this is they're cooked
you think you think that completed a
little bit more and they'd have a little
bit more of a conclusion
yeah now you guys help us to put in the
book okay this is Chester and mystery
bum same JJ
so just because some moistened bit loves
our scimitar at me doesn't mean I
screwed up the line duty